3 2 1
la révélation de cette rame inaugurale
du trapèze ils étaient nombreux mercredi
6 juillet à venir voir le lancement du
nouveau tram t13 faire saint cyr
saint-germain donc une vraie traversante
en tramway ça n'existe absolument pas
dans les yvelines donc c'est un
changement majeur il est important parce
qu'il permet dans une ville qui est un
peu compliquée comme la mienne avec une
géographie un peu complexe sur un
territoire très entendu de relier des
quartiers que d'habitude il nous faut
soit prendre la voiture se reprendre le
bus et on espère comme ça des densifier
les circulation automobile et les
circulations routières entre plusieurs
quartiers de la ville ce tram train
relie saint cyr l'école à saint germain
en laye en une demi heure avec un départ
toutes les 10 minutes en heure de pointe
et toutes les 20 minutes en heure creuse
le thé 13 a notamment pour objectif de
désengorger certains axes de circulation
avec une fréquence estimé à vingt mille
voyageurs par jour une grosse partie de
ses vingt-huit mille voyageurs sont des
voyageurs qui vont être
sur une des deux gares du nord et sud
que c'est des gars qui redit comme je le
disais le rer a au nord c'est au sud et
qui draine donc des flux de voyageurs
important et pour ce premier voyage les
riverains se montre plutôt satisfait
j'en pense que c'est une bonne idée
alors moi personnellement je
n'utiliserai pas de façon obligatoire
mais c'est vrai que je me rends souvent
à versailles pour voir des amis donc ça
me permettra d'aller jusqu'à saint cyr
et ensuite il ya les bus il ya même il
ya même le rer la ligne e n y eut donc
ça me permettra de me déplacer plus
facilement on est très très contente de
cette ligne qui va enfin s'ouvrir parce
que nous ça fait très longtemps qu'on
est sur noisy et c'était très attendu
mais certains habitants de beille et de
noisy-le-roi ont perturbé l'inauguration
du tram et le manifester contre les
nuisances sonores ya quand même un
espèce de paradoxes certaines inepties à
faire rouler un tram 100 kilomètres en
zone urbaine sur un kilomètre en fait
alors que vous voyez il est hyper en
mode de tram sur saint germain en laye
où y'a aucune habitation il roule à 30
km et le lendemain de son inauguration
le thé 13 a connu un nouveau loupé
retardé puis immobilisé pendant une
bonne partie de la matinée en garde de
bel air pour qu' il n'a pu redémarrer
que vers midi en cause problème de panne
et de matériel